All right,
we're back live.
Pretty tired this afternoon, but we got
to grind through some release materials.
I think the easiest thing we can do
right now is let's just like
let me see if I can just get the shader
into constellation.
I don't want it messing with the
constellation code is the thing cuz it's
not throw away.
We basically can just render a bunch of
uh trailers and stuff out.
this linear
of one.
I actually don't remember how it does
that.
I have 80k points, so I should be able
to test it.
It does look very cool.
Um, but the the star size are slightly
too small.
We'll see if this needs changes. If not,
we'll leave it. I want to give this a
few minutes, though.
Okay,
that makes sense.
See, they're like
the core is like transparent.
Oh, okay. It's Well, this is the web
one.
Hey Curtis, actual 3D debug ammo
is taking more time than the actual
training end.
Demo ends.
Yeah, I it takes some time. Like Java
brain is the worst possible thing, man.
It was my first language and it's just
awful.
Things get a lot simpler and see, but
it's going to take some time.
Don't use what I'm doing now as example.
This is like dumb throw away stuff at
the end of release.
Well, that's kind of funky, but um it
doesn't look like stars.
like we should learn C first. So did I,
man. So do I.
You'll see that you learn so so much
that like
it'll all become very simple to the
point that you'll look at the majority
of what people are building these days
and it's just like wow that's stupid.
Why do they have a thousand moving
pieces when they need like five
That's pretty freaking awesome.
Now this is like crazy crowded.
Did it just change? It changes the
frequency and the amplitude only, right?
Just try this
frequency and the amplitude.
Well, kind of always was going to be a
mess, right, with um this many points.
It does look like we have something
though cuz this looks nice. And if I do
a single N.
This is better, right?
Doesn't quite look like I imagined
though.
That's better. It's like almost static,
which is what you want in a plot.
Then I think I need to up the frequency
a little bit.
We don't want it to be obnoxious, right?
Like it's a dashboard.
It's supposed to be a relatively subtle
effect
there. That's it.
Yeah,
And then the size variation, it needs to
not get to be smaller than
than a specific size
because otherwise it winks out. Can't
see it.
Yeah. So like the base size
is 12, right? It needs to not be smaller
than what? Nine,
which is like the minimum.
This is nice. I think it's a little
twinkly. It's not distracting.
going to go up to 15.
Minimum size of 12.
actually. Wait, this is goes down to 20
and it has a little bit of twinkiness to
it.
Just cuz you have so many points,
they're way easier to see like this.
Can we cap it from getting too washed
out or not? Really?
This is nice and clear the individual
points.
Let me go like I have a Hang on. I sent
some screenshots.
Graphics programmer Jared. Yeah,
I have some screenshots that I sent him
before
of uh
what it looked like.
Okay. So, the stars look way cooler, but
it's more washed out here.
So, if I can match this sort of
intensity,
I think we'll be good.
tap it or
trying to think what's the best way to
do that though because
Let me just make Let's see if it's the
twinkling ones that do this.
See, this is still more washed out. This
actually doesn't have anything to do
with this.
has to do with Yes.
Okay, see that's like better, but now
it's not going to show up.
Individual stars are not going to show
up as well.
You can't actually see the individual
points very well.
They're like basically single pixels.
Uh you can now see this chart again
which is interesting.
But it's still this one is still going
to be washed out.
Let's just let's just go with um let's
go with Yes.
Like if I do it like this.
Boom. Now you can't see anything. But
actually the individual plots look
really good.
asmmptoically.
Okay,
We'll play with this for a bit cuz I
think it will make constellation look
much better. But we don't want to spend
too too much time.
You see what I mean though, right? Like
with the individual plots here.
The points are now very very clear,
which is good. I actually can make them
a little smaller if I have them this
way, which is nice.
This is like the clear star. Good. But
then when you do this, it's too much.
I think the blend factor though, that
could fix it
because this is just like blah, right?
Too much.
see like even here you can't see it.
This like this is an actual plot we
might want to do, right? Which is this
hidden size on a log like this
and you just can't see what's going on
at all.
is too bright. I can do like a single
end like this maybe.
It's still pretty washed out even like
this
cuz like here
this is actually useful, right? This is
like 512
24. You can see that the best policies
are these two.
But there's too much jank down there.
I don't know why it's just stuck doing
[ __ ] nothing.
Oh, I used the wrong one. Cool. Let me
just um
I have a feeling this is just going to
be completely stupid.
That's basically
the saturation of the original just as
clear.
If I do like all
it's expected that this is still going
to be kind of washed out, but like
I guess we could do
just max instead of add.
Is there like an RL? Is there like a max
instead of an AD?
Yeah, JL Max
there.
Oh, so much better.
Holy.
So much freaking better, right?
Oh, and it can put the corona spike back
in, right? Let's see with the corona.
Glad I'm not color blind. It's blue
green.
Red green is the common one that you
like that you plan for, right?
Usually you don't do uh red green on
stuff cuz that's like one in 20 people
or something. One in 10. One in 20
people.
Is it one in 10 men? Maybe one in 20
and forget.
You don't just plan every like you have
to be able to use colors.
Yeah, but you don't like you don't have
to design everything for all possible
color blindness, man. Like you basically
can't use interesting colors if you do
that. You basically just make everybody
color blind if you do that.
And let me see what it looked like
before I did this.
see what I sent Spencer.
All right. So, this is what we had
before.
They're more visual clutter. I can't
tell.
in the bottom left.
Uh that's because you have a ton of
points. So right here, this is like 50
points overlapping.
This is a detail of this specific sweep.
Like
if I filter it, you'll see that most of
the twinkles will go away.
It's because it's there's a one in 30
chance for each point to twinkle and
there's 50 points on top of each other
at each one of those. This is why
they're so big.
Maybe let's try something. Let's go back
to 12.
And then let's just say
we can't get smaller than 12
This is still visual clear visually nice
and clear.
If you can't get smaller than nine,
Yeah, I don't like you can't really see
the star shapes at all.
I mean, this is a lot more visually
clear.
Send this dispenser.
See what he thinks.
If this is on um
um
I guess ultimately I kind of just have
to guess
It's still a nice twinkle. It's just not
distracting.
It's good.
This is good, I think.
I make the plots with this is the
question.
This is a reasonable thing to make the
plots with.
Yeah. So like if I do like this
0.9 perf
Okay, I like that that we do like perf.
We do like 30
seconds brain stance.
I can record clips using this.
Yeah, I can record clips using this.
oh, did that just scale everything very
nicely for me? I think it did.
Let's try this.
Just fix up a couple small things.
Talking about this in Discord. Are there
any good way to encode an unordered
multi- set of items and inventory of
stuff?
So, this is the closest.
The thing is there's no fast way to do
it.
You can do better than torch, but like
I think that there's nothing within a
factor of 10 of the speed that we target
at the moment.
Yeah, the pooling is kind of [ __ ] This
kind of bottlenecks every single project
that does it.
It was a major headache during my PhD as
well.
reviewing all 500k lines from good.
Do they actually have 500k lines of
code? If they do, I'm not surprised. And
they're [ __ ] idiots.
Like the only thing that's remotely
impressive from these companies are the
base models, right? The four loops they
write over it like
are just nothing.
some pool.
No, it is it is still slow arch because
you end up with like a [ __ ] ton of
embeddings basically, right? So like
let's say that you project everything.
You have to project to a reasonable
hidden dim of like 128, right? Because
they're all overlapping. You end up with
a just stupid number of things 128
embedding. And then you end up with like
a total of 10k plus. If you look at the
drive network, they have this exact
problem and it completely [ __ ] the
project.
This is where we're going to put the
constellation overlay.
>> Yeah, exactly. So, Arch just think 128*
512 times the batch size. You kill the
memory bandwidth.
all embeddings for chest and we ran.
Yeah. So, that was just not a very smart
way to do it. That's clean. Yeah, it's
pretty nice. I think this is nice.
I'm happy with this. And then if we look
at constellation,
so constellation also got um cosmetic
upgrade with the new shader.
So, it's way clearer now when you have a
[ __ ] ton of points, but then it still
looks good on the individuals.
It's pretty clear. You can see the
individual points way better.
I do wish I could make the points just a
little bit bigger.
Let's just do 10.
I'll be happy at 10.
Yeah, just a little bit bigger, you
know.
Little extra clarity. Doesn't cost us
much.
Is there zoom?
Uh, zoom no pan at the moment. We can
easily add that [ __ ] whenever we feel
like it. I'm not creeping more features
into the release.
Uh GPU end doesn't remotely fix that
arch. What are you talking about? Like
the thing that doesn't even make sense
as a statement. What does that fix?
Like GPU is just not better most of the
time. In fact, it's much worse for a lot
of the environments.
GPUs are not just like CPUs, but faster.
This is good. Good.
Um,
we can take some videos,
I think for
we can take some videos, I think for constellation.
I have to figure how to record those at
the same time as I'm doing this.
Not think. Yeah, not thinking straight.
Yeah, it's not bandwidth to CPU and GPU,
right? Because you put the OBS on the
GPU that are small and then you form the
embeddings which are large already on
the GPU. You kill GPU, you kill the
memory bandwidth of the GPU, not the
hosted device.
Okay, be right back. I'm going to use a
restroom and then we will uh we'll do
the constellation videos and we will be
good.
Hi, Joseph. What are we actually doing
here?
Well, benching.
But, uh, aside from that, we're
currently just making the
trailer and then the articles
for the upcoming release.
So, it's pre-release work for Puffer 4.
Um,
thinking what's the easiest way to
record constellation.
And then I can just record a couple
little clips.
Let's check the article I wrote on this.
I think I was going to do this one.
Okay. I was going to do it's four
recordings. It's pretty easy.
I do that in a few minutes if I don't
bole
Yeah. So, I have about um 10 seconds to
show the full thing off and then I have
a couple easier clips to record.
I don't know why I just post random
things and they like blow up randomly.
Okay. So, we do this. We get the
recording for the trailer.
Yeah, we get the recording for the
trailer.
We get the recordings for the article.
hour 45 minutes. I think I can do that.
And then that means we're done
with the articles effectively.
And
uh if we're done with the articles,
then I can spend tonight.
I can clean up. There's one small thing
with the configs. I wanted to clean up
the build stuff. I got to fix a few
things. And I can start looking at
embeddings, which will be good. And then
after dinner, I'll have like two
hoursish at least to do that. We should
be in good shape.
Yeah, we should be in good shape.
what it's doing. It's just like stuck.
I guess I can go do the uh the API.
Not the API, the Mingru stuff.
Copy.
Well, hang on. What are the articles
listed on? Is it Are the articles theme
dependent? Because if the articles are
theme dependent, then I have to do the
entire thing on um
on a like color background.
Hey, Mystic.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure that the uh the
articles
it'll just embed on this.
So I have to do a background for
everything.
A little annoying.
This
then background. Oops.
Hang on. This needs to be like this.
One, two, three,
four.
What's up with bro? Nothing. I just made
some random post and like stuff blows up
cuz it's freaking Twitter.
I think this is fine, right? Just like
this.
I mean, I could shade these ones
differently, but I don't think there's a
point.
Yeah, this is good. We can put this, but
we want this higher up.
Yeah, this is good.
It's a nice architecture diagram.
I'll have to clean some stuff up later
with it, but it's fine.
Uh, this thing is just straight up
stuck.
Okay, actually then I can just get it
from here.
F.
Okay.
Give me the coffee talk days. They're
doing work.
Hey, in the meantime, does this [ __ ]
work? Looks like it.
given.
Oh, hey Spencer. Yo, what do you think
of the um the fig the figs?
So, I got
I also managed to slip in a nice
reabeling for it. Um,
we got this figure for the architecture
and we got these formulas
with the PUF gates.
Wait, given that in drive
combining them to one encoder with a
type attribute be faster?
Uh, yes. But I'm pretty sure that that
encoder delay like the lag is dominated
by the um road points encoder. Anyways,
that's the big one.
What do you think about the architecture
diagram?
This is it. This is the whole puffer
architecture.
Yeah, this puffer.
Um, I'm going to start rendering the
trailer stuff pretty soon. I'm actually
I'm going to do the um I'm going to
start exporting the constellation stuff
for it. I think it's pretty solid.
You know, I think I can record the uh do
the recordings based on this. Uh the
only thing I don't have is I got to fill
in like end stats for the trailer. I did
a couple little cleanups on the trailer
as well, but I need end stats.
prior to all experiments in. Well, I
want to be done with this stupid thing,
man. Like, I guess we could wait. I
could technically wait until we have all
the experiments in, but um it's just
going to give me like an extra 3 hours
of work to scramble to do right before
release instead of checking on other
stuff. If we can get the stats for like
five reasonable M's versus 3 0, that's
kind of all I need for the trailer.
and then I can like if I can finish this
stuff up then I can start helping with
embeddings cuz we got a few environments
that are going to be tough and I don't
want to add like 2,000 lines of code to
puffer for custom encoders.
I'm just adding like a temporary
recording feature to Constellation so I
can do the videos. You know,
some are going to be a bit gross.
Yeah,
I mean if you've got if you can just
grab me five M's worth, right? Like we
can definitely we can use Breakout, we
can use Pong. Ideally, we use a few
other environments.
I don't know if we have 2048 or if we
have grid or something,
Custom encoders. They're pretty messy.
Jess
Grid after enduro. Cool. Rename it to
maze while you're at it because why not?
Yeah. So, I'm just going to do uh before
dinner, I'm going to see if I can get
the clips clean for like the clean
constellation demo clips for the article
and for this uh get them into the
article.
And
I guess I can start with trailer.
H
maybe just get everything into the
articles.
Let me think. I've got like 10 seconds
to show this off. Right.
So, we land on the main screen for a
couple seconds
and then we do
we like switch the 3D graph
to like hidden size.
We'll switch to like one environment
on um the other graph. We'll click
around a little bit.
Two scenes, five scenes, two seconds
each. It's going to just be one
continuous quick clip. And then I'm
going to do four separate uh scenes for
the article. And those ones don't have
to be like two seconds. I can be a
little more relaxed with those
here. Let me just let's try the first
take.
I have to click tab to start recording
when I want to.
Then it's going to be on Z, right?
Well, that was shitty. Did I get the
message for recording?
What is it doing?
Oh, it's just moving it.
Just make sure that this is rendering
correctly before I put the time into um
It's going to have the stupid recording
icon, isn't it?
I got to come up with a better way to do
this.
So to this
this to break out.
Click
14 seconds. Okay, so a quick version of
this could work. I just have to be
quicker on the controls.
Damn it, I forgot to save it. Oh, maybe
it did it for me anyways.
I could do it with OBS so that I get
mouse movements.
Okay. So this is fine. So I can now I
can do this. So I can just do like
tap boom boom
boom boom
boom
boom.
Oh yeah, the logit's okay.
So here's what we can do, right? Start
here.
Tab. One, two. One, two. Click
two. One, two,
seven.
That's a nice demo.
Right.
Thank you. I'm trying to record
trailers.
Okay, this one is good, right? This is
No, this is 15 seconds. How'd it take 15
seconds?
Okay.
I can be faster.
Okay. Ready.
How's that? Come on. Surely that was
good.
Oh, that's a sweet demo, right? Okay,
come on. Tell me this is not an awesome
demo. Hang on 10 seconds.
That's a good demo. I like this. We win.
We just freaking win.
Send this dispenser.
Boom.
Okay.
So now all I have to do is show
That demo rocks though. That's a good
demo.
I can just use that clip.
Actually, I can use that clip from the
trailer
for constellation, right? Unless there's
something better to do with it.
Let me just try to show slower like um
like a gamma type analysis.
Let me play around with it myself first.
So it's going to be like this.
Gamma logit scale.
And then what are we going to do for
this? Gamma on logit scale. We do like
0.9.
Actually, don't even need to limit this,
do you?
Make it a nice quick rep. I'm just
making um demos is all I'm doing.
I messed it up right at the end there,
but that's a close to the demo we want.
This looks good, right?
Minute and 24 seconds.
Is the flickering in the video or is it
in the player?
and then how what about this one?
This one's kind of just like leave it on
all
I think we'll just do a quick we'll just
do this like real quick.
Hello again.
I think if I do that better, that'll be
a good clip.
So, let's try like this, right?
How's this for a little demo? 30 second
demo. I set the gamas.
I look for the logic range here.
I think that's good.
That's three nice clips.
That's three quite nice clips.
I can edit those in right now. Picks up
all the articles and we should be nicely
set.
Here's a restroom real quick. And get a
bench set in. We will do that.
Hopefully you can actually stick these
into X articles. Now
And we need a screenshot for this.
I can easily
can easily do that.
Do like this.
Let's just do hidden size.
Oops.
Hidden size.
Yes.
We could also zoom in like this.
I think this is good.
favorite feature of four
other than it being fast, the uh the
ease of like reproducing experiments.
It's really easy to replicate [ __ ] in
this.
There's like too much noise, isn't
there? What What's the burrito set look
like?
The Chuck Norris of RL. I'll take that
any day.
Okay,
this is good. This I can work with,
right?
I think we just do the whole freaking
screenshot now.
Let's go find um
there's an illustration There.
do I edit this to be nice full
resolution?
Really big screenshot.
He works on um Puffer Drive and made a
funny artwork for this.
So, let's see.
All I got to do is figure out where we
put this
There we go.
That looks nice.
I think it's good that we put these at
the top.
Okay, this is nice.
This two are done.
this one. I think I can just use the
freaking table of solve times as an
image
or I can use the um
the like GIF
from the trailer.
Nice.
But
Okay, I got a couple things to do before
dinner.
So, I think I'm going to go do that and
then I'm going to
after dinner,
I will come back and
we will do some work on custom network
architectures and embeddings and
experiments and all that. Yeah.
All right. Uh, for folks watching, thank
you very much. Puffer.ai for all the
things. Star the puffer on GitHub. I'll
be back in about an hour. Uh, Discord if
you want to get involved. Follow on X at
not these numbers.